that is disgusting
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Harry Kane he's a
premier league Golden Boot award-winning
Striker for Tottenham one of the most
prolific goal scorers of all time and
the captain of England's national team
but Holly fare today in a
pressure-packed high-stakes match
against the wings of death I guess only
time will tell Harry Kane welcome to the
show thanks for having me thanks for
having me how are you around spicy food
before we get started yeah I'm not I'm
not great it's not something I normally
normally have a lot so I'm interested to
see how we get on today were you ready
to get started let's do it let's do it
[Music]
over here yeah
okay okay
so far not too bad there we go yeah
[Music]
I was expecting a little bit worse I
think I was like
okay take your wins where you can get
them here it's actually quite nice there
you go maybe you were a hot sauce person
maybe I've just been missing out you
know what I mean
um that's not too bad I'm all right so I
want to congratulate you on another
record-breaking season scoring 30 plus
Premier League goals for the second time
in your career and then taking over
Wayne Rooney to become England's
all-time leading scorer every season has
its own meaning its own lessons how will
you remember this season and the Arc of
your career yeah this one uh you know
from a from a personal point of view has
been pretty special
um to break the the England all-time
goal scorer record was uh just a dream
come true really
um
we have so many amazing players that I
watched growing up
so many strikes
so many strikes and scoring goals
um it's nice to be at the top of that
list now so truly special and yeah for
another another 30 goal season which is
great
um so yeah overall you know I feel like
I'm improving I'm getting better even
though I'm uh a little bit older now so
I'm excited for for what's to come
a little bit of milk
it's happening yeah just a little a
little tingle on the on the front there
[Music]
okay let's do it yeah
I found that one a little easier
great did you there's a little lever
pulling that happens you know that's
like uh I feel like the first one was a
little bit of a like a a little kick and
then this one's just not too bad you
know it's like a game you know you
settle into the game when you when you
get that first contest you know what I'm
saying that's what happened you got your
first hit now you don't feel like the
curry I I do like a curry back back home
in England so so it's kind of familiar
yeah I think there's a yeah I'm quite
familiar with that taste so
so as an American it's wild to read
about these European youth football
academies where you know at such a young
age the next messy the next Ronaldo the
next Kane is Anointed at at what age do
you think Talent can actually be
observed and then what's the first
memory you have of yours being
recognized in a meaningful way yeah
that's a great question you know uh like
someone like me I've been at the club
I'm at now since I was 11 years old yeah
so that's almost that's 18 years I've
been there and uh I think that's too
early to really tell
um you know if a player is going to be a
great player or not I think yeah that 15
16 Mark was when I started seeing like a
difference in me and you know my
confidence started growing and you know
people started looking at me maybe in a
bit of a different light and it's like
okay this this coup could have a future
so
um yeah when I went on talking to you
know parents or you know with young kids
who want to play football I'm just
telling them that up until kind of 14 15
just let them enjoy it let them kind of
uh feel their way into it because the
most important thing is that they're
happy right they want to right they want
to be enjoying what they're doing uh and
then once you kind of see physically how
they are at 1560 and that's when you get
to know what they're what they're gonna
be like then it's rather remarkable that
you and David Beckham came out of the
Ridgeway Rovers that's right yeah what's
special about that Youth Academy yeah
I'm not too sure that was our local so
me and David were both from a place
called chingford uh in East London and
um yeah we kind of both ended up at this
team obviously he was 10 or so years uh
before me maybe uh and yeah they just
had a good setup you know they had good
coaches there they had a good
environment you know when I went there I
just went there to enjoy it play
football with friends and uh that was
kind of the start for me so it brings
back some good memories there we go I
love that walk down memory later you're
ready to move on here I'm ready to Wing
number three
got a zesty lemon pepper okay waiting
here from the Crabby Shack
yeah
a little uh little kick to it yeah right
yeah a bit more than number two I think
and that's how it's kind of gonna go
from here that's me being honest with
you Harry I'm transparent you know it's
just like real easy just getting into it
yeah add a little uh yeah a little trail
that at least
seven more to go the little bit worrying
so but you know what you're somebody who
can conquer the mental all right you
want to be where you were now if it
wasn't for that I didn't see it in your
eyes right now seven more reps seven
more reps let's do it
so you and teammate young man's son have
set all kinds of Premiership records for
Combined goals is there anything that
you can point to that makes your
partnership so telepathic you know the
first kind of three four years we didn't
have that amazing record that we have
now it took us time to build that uh I
think getting to know
obviously how each other play on the
pitch but also what you like off the
pitch as well and we started to become
closer in Friendship we started to know
each other a little bit better and then
yeah I've just been come with you know
understanding each other's games you
know he's a fantastic player a lot of
skill and now kind of whenever I'm on
the ball he knows there's runs to make
him without thinking looking or playing
it straight away and uh yeah we've just
been both of us have I think just
improved along that along that process
and become a bit more prolific so uh
yeah he's a great player but a really
great guy as well do you have a personal
favorite goal of yours in your career
and if so can you paint the picture for
us
I think my favorite goal um
was my England debut goal um it was at
Wembley our home stadium I come on for
Wayne Rooney who was someone you know I
looked up to growing up that moment and
he's running off the pitch I'm running
on and I was just so excited and then
within I think it was about two about
three minutes of the game uh I scored my
first goal you know it was like a ball
kind of flowing over to the back post I
headed it down into the goal and just
that emotion in that moment was just you
know something that's hard to describe
it was just I had all my family there in
the stadium at my friends my wife Kate
and uh yeah just to kind of share that
moment as an England player and you know
no one can ever take that away from me
you know I still remember it so vividly
now so that's that's probably one that
always saves my favorite because it
meant so much
[Music]
pleasantly surprised but I feel like
this is just a real slow warm up into
what's to come smart man
[Music]
and this is kind of
one that takes a little bit of a jump
here or starts off kind of nice
kind of sweet approachable yeah
ah
yeah
it's got like a little um
little sweet barbecue situation but just
yeah it's just like there it's just like
there's a sharpness
exactly yeah
so I'm fascinated by your dream to one
day be a field goal kicker in the NFL
and I'm a Chicago Bears fan okay okay
and a few years ago we lost a playoff
game on what was famously called the
double doink okay it was a kick that
went off the upright and then off the
crossbar doinking rather loudly along
the way and then out to lose the game
and it's crystallized In My Memory like
one of my most crystallized sports fan
memories and I'm curious if you would
all sympathize empathize think about the
plight of the field goal kicker a
position that naturally lends itself to
being defined by its biggest failures
and lowest moments yeah that's that's
the that's the thing with the field okay
you know they're not probably the most
famous player on the team and not the
one maybe they get famous when they mess
up exactly so you know but they're
probably maybe other than the
quarterback under the most pressure when
they're on the pitch because you know
it's how many NFL games go down to a
winning field goal right and you win or
lose on the field goal so in terms of
pressure you know there's not many kind
of specific moments in sport like a NFL
kicker so I think that's why it's so
tough and like you said if you if you
miss one people remember that forever so
uh you've got to be pretty good to you
know stay good in those moments maybe
that's what makes it fun for you have
you ever thought about that maybe but it
depends if I if I make them or don't
maybe that's the risk maybe that's the
feeling yeah
you know it's very you know you'll have
the moment to be the hero but also you
have the moment to be the villain so is
that you know is that real balance but I
think that's what inside drives you know
athletes or the top competitors
to push them push themselves to those
sort of limits so we'll see we'll see
I'm ready so this next one is the Los
Calientes Rojo here
[Music]
so last year you posted that your New
Year's resolution for the past decade
has been to improve what are the
greatest lengths that you've gone to in
order to master a part of the game you
know I did read about you training with
only your left foot for three months
once yeah that left foot when I was
I think that was about 7 17 that time
maybe 18 and uh that I could use my left
foot I was good with my left foot but I
looked around I looked at the top
players and I thought well if I want to
be you know the best I need to be able
to pretty much score in my left foot as
simple as the right part of my left foot
and uh I said look I'm just gonna
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna use this uh I'm gonna use
this time to uh just practice my lift so
in training I lit uh literally every
shot I hit was with my left every time I
touched the ball I'll dribble with my
left passing my left foot got to the
stage where wherever I had a finish on
my right my left I felt natural on both
and uh yeah stuff like that is really
kind of excelled me and I feel like
separated me from you know some of the
other players who were probably just
says uh talented as I was at that age
um but that kind of mindset helped me to
get where I am now
[Music]
spicy shark is there a bike
it indeed does
[Music]
yeah for sure yeah
in the bottom
and see that there's the spice just
sitting there just
taunting you
okay A bit already a bit of a nose it's
all gonna loosen up here
what's that time
are you at all envious of how American
sports stars position themselves in the
Press like have you observed a
difference between the British and
American media in terms of how they
treat athletes uh yeah I think so I
think
um you know I'd probably say American
athletes are a bit more open and a bit
more
um
maybe just say less guarded in their
approach interest how they talk in the
media
um maybe over in England you have to be
a little bit more careful with what you
say and how you say things I feel like
you know the public event ain't sitting
there knowing someone's kind of guarding
against certain questions or they don't
want to be have to say the only science
and they say maybe the correct answer if
you wanna but um yeah sometimes you want
to just say the truth yeah yeah pretty
much yeah pretty much but uh obviously I
understand how it works and you know
sometimes you just you can't do that but
um I definitely feel like over over here
in the States you can uh you know the
athletes are a little more open to doing
that
[Music]
it's still got a spicy shark on my
tongue so I know
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
super similar to The Spicy shark right
we're just like a massive jump I feel
like this the shark is a very spicy
number six for this lineup so it can be
kind of jarring you know you're like
this is how we're starting the second
half we got four more to go so it's kind
of nice the thing about
Chico over here is it kind of kicks in a
little bit later you know like as I
think that you're catching yeah
reflecting back on your career from the
youth game to now what's the most
memorable trick play or elaborate set
piece you ever recall participating in
oh good question so
um there was one for England we had we
was playing Panama in the World Cup in
2018 and uh we had like two guys on the
ball about 40 yards out they played a
like a pass to the right side to the
left side we were at all our position
you know what I think about now we all
had our set positions he kind of crossed
it over to me on the far side and then I
headed it back across goal to one of my
teammates and and it worked we literally
we worked on it and training the day
before the game and you know sometimes
you work on this stuff and it's like you
know you never you'll get to the game
and it never works you know people are
in different positions
but this one just worked perfectly and
we ended up scoring from it so that's
one that you know I always remember
I've heard about this uh the bomb the
bomb Beyond insanity
what have you heard
I've just heard it's brutal and
unenjoyable
well I guess we'll find out we will
[Music]
that's not nice no not at all that's not
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
not the others
I feel like you could have with a nice
bit of food or whatever right even when
they were spicy you saw some sort of
redeeming culinary quality not in this
one though
[Music]
I just
I just burned everything in your mouth I
know I know and then here we are on an
interview show and I'm about to ask you
a question right right
now it is getting off
what in your mind is the greatest
football Anthem or chant of all time
well
Tottenham have a good one for me
they assume he's one of our own which
come about
I scored a
that's called a hat trick in a one of my
first games
um it was a Europa League game at the
time
and uh
I just started hearing him seeing he's
one of our own he's one of he's one of
our own and uh yeah it was just because
I've come through the academy because
I've been Hometown Hometown hero that
was it it was kind of uh yeah their way
of kind of singing a song for me and uh
it really like Hit me hard it was
amazing to hear and uh yeah I was local
to the stadium that's pretty rare in our
sport to have that so yeah to have them
sing he's one of our own you know feels
like I'm I'm part of them I'm part of
the fan group and that's pretty special
in the way that you just took the bomb
to the chest I think you're man of the
people Legacy is only going to grow from
here I think so I hope so after after
doing it I'm doing this for everyone
right now
wow that is like a
it's crazy it's intense always a part of
the show where you don't know where it's
gonna go because that has to be the
spiciest thing you've ever eaten in your
life out and the most probably the most
disgusting as well there's no way anyone
would ever eat that
to have life an enjoyable meal there's
nowhere
there's two more to go as well by the
way right
for better or worse this next one is the
watermelon ghost
I feel like my mouth caught me anymore
right it's scorched Earth
how bad can it be
[Music]
I feel like I can't feel anything
yeah I feel like my mouth is just
completely uh
the hard work is over here Harry the
hard work is all over you know once you
get through the bomb you can take on
anything yeah I feel like but again that
was like
[Music]
find something you like
the the bomb one is just at the space of
a source
do you have any sort of strategy or
Rules of Engagement when it comes to
working the Reps during a match or is
that kind of communication just purely
visceral yeah is impossible to spool you
know you have to be able to
try and uh help get help in any way
possible and you know sometimes if
you're come just shouting at the ref all
the time or you know he's going to maybe
take that the other way and almost you
know just put you to one side give you
no decisions or whatever it may be you
know the ref is always
yeah to you know do his job but he's a
he's a human at the end of the day so
um you know I'm someone who likes to
talk to the refs and try and understand
some of the decisions they've made
because I know and they're not always
going to be perfect
yeah ultimately it's just about you know
figuring out what type of ref you got
and then trying to like
um
psychology and see what works for you
yeah in any given situation yeah
all right oh
we had a bit actually
[Music]
how much we talking
what was that is that good yeah that's
actually that's perfect that's perfect
right Cheers Cheers
going in
I love it
wow yeah
another crazy one but I know I know but
it's all over straight out my nose
pretty much it's all over you did it the
worst is behind you and just one more
question to close things out you know I
came into this experience with a new
greater appreciation for the sport and
for you Harry Kane forever a Harry Kane
supporter on this side of the table but
over the course of the research there's
so much just strange lingo things that I
needed definitions for and I think now
is the perfect time to bounce some of
those things off of you to see if you
can Define these things while your brain
slow roasts and hot sauce okay yeah
let's do it what's a fox in the Box
fox in the box is like a just a shop you
know like nippy kind of player
scores the goals but don't do much else
if there's a fox in the Box they just
score goals close by a few tap-ins yeah
what's a dead ball specialist Deadpool
Deadpool specialist is um
that's a you know like a free kit yeah
or a corner kick yeah and they just
they're like top of their game in that
so they'll score loads of free kicks in
their corner corner kicks and stuff are
always just perfectly in the Box
um so yeah that's a Deadpool what's a
howler
a howler is like a real bad mistake
so so uh
if you're like a goalkeeper and you that
one for your legs or one you're supposed
to catch that's the house yeah yeah well
let me tell you something Harry Kane no
howlers today taking on the wings of
death and living to tell the tale and
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you this camera
this camera this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
so guys thanks for having me on the show
um just finished my season you know I've
got some commitments coming up just got
my Harry Kane Foundation that I launched
last year so uh excited to explore the
mental health side of uh life and trying
to help as many people as possible so uh
appreciate all your support appreciate
you guys having me on the show
um and yeah I've done it I've done that
I've done that I've done the hot wings
I'm proud
thank you very much thank you so good
yeah
I know and then this is my uh this is my
partying advice to you just be careful
around the eyes and like touching your
face okay right now hands yeah we're
contaminated yeah right here yeah so
just a thorough washing of the hands
because if it sticks with you and any
hot sauce mistake you can possibly make
I've made many of them all right so
we'll just like look into the camera
here and just be like it's hotter okay
yeah all right
thank you
guys will look at each other
amazing cheers guys thank you thank you
thank you so much for watching today's
video I have a very exciting new product
alert last year hot ones brought the
heat to the freezer aisle with our first
ever hot ones boneless chicken bites
well now we are bringing even more heat
to the freezer aisle with our brand new
hot ones chicken strips made with our
first ever seasoned blend two boldly
seasoned varieties you have the spicy
garlic featuring The Classic garlic
Fresno with mild heat and garlic blasted
goodness and Smoky habanero with the
tropical medium spice of our Los
Calientes Rojo we took the sauces that
you know and love and with a little
kitchen magic turned it into the perfect
season blend that go great on our new
hot ones chicken strips to find hot ones
chicken strips near you visit
hotoneschallenge.com that's
hotwingschallenge.com snack em dip them
make them the perfect party platter
thank you
foreign
[Music]